The interior of your home
is a self-reflection of who you
are as a person.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So much of interior
design can seem daunting.
There's so many choices
that are available.
I'm going to teach you
how to find your style,
how to work with
pattern, and how
to use lighting so
everyone can look good
who comes over to your house.
Go into your closet.
Take a few of the
articles of clothing
and drape them across
your living room,
and see like, oh my
god, I love that color!
So what you look good in,
you're going to feel good in.
In every project,
this is how I start.
I call these vibe trays.
It keeps the materials
in one place.
We have stone, tile, wood.
All of these textures
work together.
And that's what I love,
is being experimental.
Color is absolutely
nothing to be afraid of.
Living without color is
like living without love.
It evokes so many emotions.
Yellow makes everyone happy.
There are many things
you can do to make
a small space feel larger.
For example, having pieces
that are up on legs,
or a coffee table
that maybe has glass.
High gloss paint can
really expand the space,
because you have
reflectiveness and dimension.
And it looks so [MUTED] good.
[CHUCKLING]
I want to take some of
the mystery out of design,
so you feel confident and you
can make incredible decisions,
and make a beautiful home.
Stay curious, take risks, and
beautiful things will happen.
I'm Kelly Wearstler, and
this is my MasterClass.